kyle freeland will be making his tenth
start first five as huey said kind of a
feeling out process getting his legs
underneath him again the last four have
been very good and we'll naturally focus
in
on the middle finger and hope that we
don't have to discuss it at all and
there's not an issue with that blister
wraps it to left field that's a fair
ball headed to the corner
around first and on his way to second
loki bet starts tonight the same exact
way he did last night with a double to
the left field corner
and turner hits about 800 against the
rockies or it feels that way and he'll
drive it towards right coming on
blackman slides and makes the grab
bets thought about going and wisely put
on the brakes as charlie uncorked a
laser to third nice play by blackman and
wright
one out bets at second base and max
muncie to face the left-hander freeland
and to the center field moki bets with a
big jump he's coming home
the throw by hanson will be cut off and
it's one-nothing dodgers
max muncie with an rbi his 53rd of the
year it's an outstanding read by mookie
betts he had to freeze on a line drive
to right from justin turner but he read
the arc of this ball the flight of it
off the bat and was off right away
freeze on a line drive but not if you
know where the outfielders are and not
if you can read the ball he had one
hesitation step and he was off and with
his speed that is enough of a jump
one to nothing we go to the bottom of
the first walker bueller
his 19th start of the year nine and one
a three and a quarter era 114 innings
trevor story
249 overall but so far
not his best month here in july he's
just seven for 38 for 184 average
and he gets stories swinging
first strikeout of the night for walker
bueller and now they're loaded up for
freeland well now you have freelancing
and yeah advantage bueller but if if
kyle can get it in play
i know he got the little hamstring from
a few weeks ago but
if he's right he runs well
he gets this in the air to left field
matt
will tap
pollock underneath
and kyle freeland gets it done
to tie up the game that's just so kyle
freeland isn't it yep second rbi
of the season for kyle i love the
aggressiveness too go ahead i mean aj
pollock's strong strong arm he throws it
right on the money
but the slides good too i like this just
slide right through those legs
right towards the plate don't deviate
from it that left foot gets in there on
the subaru super mode before the tag
this ball game's tied up
top of the third inning a 1-1 game here
comes the red-hot mookie bets
yard for the 14th time this season
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rookie has begun to get hot
and that is from a lot of hits down the
left field line but the true sign of
somebody that is really locked in is
when you start to see power to the
opposite field
and this home run to right center was a
very good swing so tying around to
second with two outs and rogers now
bring up ryan mcmahon
and this ball line to center field this
will tie up the game rogers will score
easily mcmahon will get a double
as the center fielder bellager was swung
over to left center ryan mcmahon coming
through with two outs
i like this swank from matt cut fastball
and then it splits the gap
as long as the hands come through on the
subaru super mow
and where pallinger was playing i mean
he was playing in left left center like
it was a right-handed pole hitter and
mookie betts trying to get over there by
that time it was
bellinger that had to
corral that brendan rodgers at the plate
ground ball to short charging taylor
and pujols able to hang on to the bag
with his right foot
so rogers is out
albert stretches and leans slash falls
into it and it looks like one of his
feet yep goes up onto the top of the bag
and catches
rogers left foot as he goes across the
bag that's the stumble and fall by
rogers but albert does a nice job making
sure he catches the ball and keeping the
foot on the bag so one out for max
muncie
if muncie can get him home again
and max goes the other way to the left
look he's gonna come home here comes the
throw from hillary not there and bet
scores muncie does it again driving in
mookie and the dodgers lead it three to
two
the base hit for muncie goes down to
second on the throw
but drives in his second run of the game
once he moves up on the throw and mookie
really pushed the envelope cutting those
bases tight you know evil waving him in
they were running on hilliard's arm
he watched the trajectory of the throw
it goes up he doesn't really get into it
that ball's got some altitude to it
first pitch to pollock
and he hammers one to left
it is back and it is gonna homerun aj
pollock on the first pitch he sees from
michael gibbons
home run number 13 for pollock and the
dodgers lead four to two
aj pollock with a rocket shot to left
it's a slider that doesn't break much
and gets another extra base hit
beds looking to go four for four coming
up
[Applause]
push this one in the air to right field
and fairly deep and this one's not going
to be caught
and into second base
is betts and he's hobbling into second
that ball was deflected by hampson and
then all of a sudden i think blackman
gets hit by the deflection knocks the
ball out of his glove
just got
the last look of bentz arriving at
second base and as he did he didn't look
especially healthy he's coming out of
the game
but that is where dodger fans are
worried looks like he's dragging that
right leg
max muncie will lead things off in the
top of the eighth inning
and muncie clobbers one deep to right
fail this paws car
maxwell swinging the silver hammer in
colorado and that makes it five two
[Applause]
[Applause]
second home run of the game for muncie
it's nine to two rockies down to their
final out
looks to crawl
broke is bad that goes into fair
territory nunez
feeds baity and that is your ball game
and the dodgers
have cut the west lead to one big big
night
for max muncie